it's time for the draft the match up
draft it's a Thursday tradition in
season kind of hard to do it not in
season all right
the first pick determined by the trivia
question and Christopher here it is the
Giants returning to Eli Manning again
this week because Daniel Jones has a
high ankle sprain Eli's start will be
exactly one year to the day of his last
victory December 9 2018 which NFC East
team did he beat in that game that's the
question he gets a 1 out of 3 guests you
give me frickin Jim Turner a kicker from
the 70s the other day and this is what
he gets
go ahead who was it the Washington
Redskins I complained long enough for
you to google it well no I mean you know
I just you know the Cowboys and the
Eagles were in the playoffs last year it
was pretty easy to figure out i
strenuously object you want the first
pick I'll give it to you no I won't
forget a Bill Belichick versus Andy Reid
that's the first one that I'm gonna go
with right there that's the one I'm
extremely excited to see that matchup
right there you know we've talked a
little bit about you know of course what
the Patriots did last year in the AFC
Championship game really a defensive
game plan and coverages that I've never
seen anybody do in the history of the
NFL it was gutsy and smart and all of
that and now what will be the next move
by both coaches and of course Kansas
City's offense has not been hitting on
all cylinders as of late last week was
the first time we saw the Patriots
defense get torched a few times and you
know there's some similarities here yeah
it's a big armed quarterback with some
really fast receivers at its disposal
and I just I'm intrigued by that matchup
this Sunday
yeah and and look we talked about it
earlier how will Andy Reed anticipate
what Bill Belichick is going to do how
will they react on the fly to what they
see I think it's gonna be a critical
game of in-game adjustments halftime
adjustments second-half adjustments to
figure out how the Patriots are
deploying and also you know defensively
what will Steve spagnolo and company do
to try to continue the woes that the
Patriots have suffered because last year
the Patriots were able to put in
together late offensively to win the AFC
championship this year they don't have
the answer so it becomes even more
important right for the New England
defense try to shut down the Kansas City
offense right I'm I'm taking a matchup
that I blurted out earlier in the show
and I'm glad you didn't go there first I
am far more intrigued by Kyle Shanahan
versus Sean Payton yeah because they are
the two masters of coming up with the
plays where you or I could throw the
pass the guy who is wide open the play
that blows wide open in the running game
we've seen it from Peyton over the years
we've seen it from Shanahan a lot this
year and they are playing in perfect
right no perfect conditions no weather
to worry about in the Superdome yeah the
49ers will have their bodies adjusted
they stayed in Florida all week note
this is a no excuses high-stakes game
for the 49ers the opportunity to try to
put themselves in position win the
division try to get the number one seed
the Saints currently hold the number one
seed this game you know is I think even
bigger than last week's 49ers Ravens
game I think Gris we were fascinated
because it was a potential Super Bowl
preview yeah this is a far more
significant game in the NFC as to who's
gonna have to play wildcard weekend
who's gonna be on the road wildcard
weekend because it could be the 49ers
and which team is gonna end up with a
number one seed I think the winner of
this game is has a very good chance at
being the number one seed and if you're
the Seahawks yeah right who you're
rooting for in this one oh well I guess
you're gonna root for
that's a good question who are you gonna
root for I was gonna say Saints right
off the bat I guess still the Saints
right you just want the Saints out of
there so well no you know no you still
have to beat the 49ers a week 17 so so
look at the Saints out of the
conversation make week 17 one seed or
five seed get the Saints out of there
I'm rooting for the 49ers if I'm a
Seahawks fan cuz I know I still have to
beat the 49ers week 17 or I'm not
winning the division anyway well I'm
trying to think right now
I mean the soul you know what what if
what is the tiebreak are gonna come down
to as far as the the the Seahawks I
think I think it it because if the
Seahawks lose weeks of saying there's a
tie it may be like
ranked the victory yeah maybe because
both of loss of the Ravens right now and
then you know yeah you're right it would
be the loss to each other and another
NFC opponents oh okay yeah you're right
that's that's a good question that I
didn't even think about that you're
right
but I'm with you my cousin really
awesome they're both defenses that are
really good
both top-ten defenses these to play
callers and game plan designers are
gonna be gonna have to be at their best
if they want their team to win so I'm
with you there
alright I'm gonna go to Baltimore
Buffalo a game that is kind of under the
radar from one of the better games of
the day on Sunday and this is a
Baltimore offense that's the number two
offense in football it's the Buffalo
defense that's the number three defense
in football and the specific matchup I'm
really kind of wanna watch is is Lamar
Jackson verse Tremaine Edmonds and Matt
Milano the two middle linebackers for
the Buffalo Bills you know without
saying the front seven verse you know
but where I find that intriguing is
those two linebackers are one of the
better linebacker duo's in all of
football
they're extremely athletic they're great
in the pass game they're awesome
sideline to sideline in the run game the
kind of athletes that could be a pain in
the butt for Lamar Jackson when he does
run on the outside so I'm intrigued by
that matchup all together of course Greg
Roman and Sean McDermott and all that
but just that an alone when those guys
are spying Lamar Jackson and then when
he does get out and on the edge these
are two linebackers that can that can
run him down and have tremendous speed
and you know can play that way sideline
to sideline so I'm excited to see that
see I rarely have ever done this and I'm
reluctant to do it but I'm gonna go
ahead and do it I'm not gonna wait til
next round to do it I'm doing it now
yeah because for a guy who and we just
started this segment with you
complaining about Josh al and not
getting enough recognition why in the
hell is your matchup not Lamar Jackson
versus Josh out well because your search
sometimes I know that's retired I don't
want you to answer it let me finish yeah
I because we are searching for the next
Peyton Manning Tom Brady right and what
if once Tom Brady's gone the bills take
over that division and what if the
Ravens are in the process of taking over
the AFC North and what can
to do so for as long as Lamar Jackson is
the starting quarterback this could be
the first matchup between these two guys
that we could see every year we could
see it in the playoffs I am fascinated
by you know because we've looked at the
whole round-robin Lamar Jackson Patrick
mahomes deshaun Watson as we search for
the next great quarterback rivalry
it could be staring right at us this
Sunday in Josh Allen and Lamar Jackson
in shame on you for not putting Josh
Allen in that mix with Lamar Jackson you
the guy that's trying to bang the drum
for Jo it for Josh Allen well I a listen
yeah I can't argue it wasn't really
anything you said you know sometimes
what happens to me is I get to in the
football weeds and I think about actual
matchups like when they're on the field
and you're you know you're better at
looking at it that way I don't know we
think of it that way because I'm always
going to go who's going head to head
that's somewhere my mind goes so I'm
sorry but you're right I mean I don't
even know if that pick should count for
you but okay I just picked Lamar Jackson
for somebody and you're gonna piggyback
off of it but either way you're right
that I picked the better matchup and
well it's the sexier matchup because
it's two quarterbacks and Josh Allen has
superstars traits as we see every week
we see things where we go whoa that's
Brett Favre type of throw and then it's
you know a really impressive run and
scramble so I get you all right so good
pick by you you're still a jerk but good
pick I think I think I'm gonna go to the
night I'm think I'm just gonna make but
make an old simple bears old line verse
Shikata I mean a bear's D line verse the
Cowboys o line all right because I look
at it like this I think that's where
this games going to be won or lost
tonight I think the Bears their front
Khaleel Mac Leonard Floyd one of them
are going to have to make a play whether
that's a strip sack fumble TIPA pass in
the air hit dak Prescott as he's
throwing in the ball pops in the air I
don't think the Bears can win without
that type of play I I really don't
because I don't think their offense will
be able to move the ball consistently on
Dallas's defense I think that'll be a
struggle and I think they're gonna have
to rely on their defense to give them
the short field at least one time
tonight and whether that's Coolio Mac or
Quan Smith or somebody like that making
a play that front seven of the Bears is
gonna have to make a play tonight for
them to pull out this victory against
the Dallas Cowboys and will Dallas smash
mathema with the Ezekiel Elliott and do
all that it's that's intriguing to me
yeah I agree with you and look the this
late in the season on a Thursday night
you never know what you're gonna get
because in April it looks good by
December it may not and even though both
teams are six and six a significant game
tonight and that's a significant matchup
in it I'm gonna go to Sunday in the
desert a rematch of Super Bowl 43 that
was the first Super Bowl I ever
personally attended the epic between the
Cardinals and the Steelers the Steelers
desperately need this win and they need
to be able to control Kyler Murray he
was off the injury report completely on
Wednesday had a hamstring problem last
week he's fine he's healthy
calimary against that Steelers front
seven how are they gonna be able to
corral this guy are they gonna be able
to corral him are they gonna be able to
keep up with him is he gonna be able to
get rid of the football make quick
decisions against the defense that will
be as good as any he's ever seen the
Steelers need this win badly but Murray
has been I don't want to say spectacular
this year but he's done enough to make
me think that next year he's gonna be
the Lamar Jackson he's gonna be the guy
that we talk about every week if they
can get some help around that's right it
took a year for it'll it took a year for
Jackson to get to that point it took a
year from a homes to get to that point
because he was on the bench all of his
rookie season but I feel like the next
big thing next year is gonna be Kyler
Murray and this is the biggest test yet
for him and and it makes you know even
though the Cardinals are done that
they're not giving up court are not
folding the tents I think they didn't
look great against the Rams but I think
that that matchup given the significance
of the Steelers can they solve Kyler
Murray it's gonna be a major factor in
whether or not the Steelers can get that
16 I would imagine that the the
Cardinals are gonna be pissed off about
their performance last week too which is
more dangerous for Pittsburgh well I'm
with you with Kyla Murray if they can
just improve that offensive line a
little bit whether it's the draft or
free agency get him another weapon or
two in the past game
yeah I've seen enough this year to go oh
he has a chance to be really special you
know Lamar Jackson and Patrick mahomes
they got to take over teams that were
playoff caliber type teams they had a
lot of the pieces in place you know
Arizona has a little
work to do to build some help around
Kyla Murray alright that's it for the
week 14 matchup draft Sims has and
agreed versus Bill Belichick Lamar
Jackson versus the bills linebackers the
Cowboys o-line versus the Bears d-line
I've got calcium Burgess Sean Payton
Lamar Jackson versus Josh howdy right at
Brynn juries no it's not chopped season
this is to Steelers front 7 versus
caliber
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports